e e
[Music]
good evening uh welcome to the first
finance committee meeting
uh
2025 um you'll notice uh there will be
quite a few
um pieces of legislation we'll have
first reading only reading and be
suspending which is normally not the way
we do that however typically this
meeting the first meeting of the year
there's carryover situations because the
last meeting was the first part of
December we have almost a month in
between meetings and uh business needs
to keep moving forward so um we'll try
to keep this going and keep it moving as
quick as we can the first item I have to
bring up is temporary resolution
1-25 a resolution to authorize the city
departments to dispose of city property
no longer needed via auction or Internet
auction in 2025 and to declare an
emergency and this is coming from law uh
committee and councilman greates yes
thank you um yeah yes this is a piece
that the city needs to pass it's
required by the orc that we pass it
before we start to um dispose of
unneeded property via auction and
because we want to use the internet
auction or use the internet for part of
the auction we would like to get it
passed soon um so they can start so the
Departments can start getting rid of
that property so we're going to ask for
one reading with Mr bisek as my
second and um when is the auction temp
be scheduled
they would when's the auction going to
be go ahead Stephanie the internet
auctions are ongoing so they're constant
okay but the the city auction is usually
in September It's usually the first week
in September right I knew it was later
on the year yep okay yep thank you
yep uh next item is temporary resolution
2-25 a resolution to support in support
of the Ohio Municipal League's challenge
of AT&T's tariff application at the
Public Utilities Commission of Ohio and
to declare an emergency also coming from
law committee and councilman crat yes uh
this is legislation in support of a
challenge filed by the Ohio Municipal
League against AT&T's tariff change and
law director Hall do you want to provide
more information on that sure I'm happy
too so the Ohio Municipal League sent us
a notice like they sent all Ohio
municipalities um last week indicating
that they would like to challenge AT&T's
proposed tariff change before the Public
Utilities Commission of Ohio so what
that tariff change would do would be to
allow AT&T to charge any political
subdivision such as ourselves a
municipality whenever they're required
to relocate their utilities in our right
of way this is the city of Lancaster's
right of way and when they have to move
their infrastructure so that we can put
our infrastructure in now they pay for
that themselves it's it's a condition of
being in our right of way but this
tariff change which the Supreme Court
has already said could override anything
that the municipalities pass um would
allow them to start charging us for
moving their utilities in our RightWay
and so this could add thousands and
thousands of dollars to all of the
utility infrastructure projects and I
thought it was you know pretty NE
necessary to get this before you and to
you know help support the Ohio Municipal
league and in challenging that change if
the if the UC does nothing then in 30
days the um the Tariff change just goes
into effect um the goal is to get enough
of these together that hopefully we can
have the Pu um be willing to have an
evidentiary hearing maybe and and you
know set aside some time to do a little
bit more um consideration before they
just allow it to to pass by attrition so
thank you and because of timing to join
that we need to suspend right
and I will be your second yes sir
good uh next item is temporary
resolution
3-25 resolution to authorize the
Lancaster Police Department to apply for
the
2025 26 drug use prevention Grant coming
from Safety Committee councilman please
check uh thank you chair wolfinger this
is a regularly uh scheduled annual piece
of legislation that the police
department applies for every year uh
this funding helps fund the Dare program
for the 2025 2026 year so um once again
we'll be asking for a waiver of the
second and third readings and council
member s will be my second on this okay
thank you Mr chair and when is the
application
due um Chief do we have we won't apply
for May May okay and why would we do
what suspension this is just to get the
ball rolling help them get their
paperwork together and everything so we
can get the grant applied for and ready
to go it takes some time it takes some
time it takes time to get everything
together and this legislation will
authorize the police department to begin
that process of bringing everything
together
okay next item is uh temporary
resolution
4-25 a resolution to appropriate from
the unencumbered balance and amend the
certificate of Appropriations with the
county auditor in the Wastewater
replacement and Improvement fund 623
6023 and authorize the issuance of then
and now certificate for payment of bills
coming from water water pollution
control Council me yes thank you Mr
chairman uh we actually have uh three
annual pieces up this evening uh this
first one um allocates some carryover
into the Wastewater Improvement fund and
I didn't know if uh superintendent Nixon
or wet or someone wanted to speak to
that but it's it's um it's an annual
piece we do every year mhm so okay
apparently and then no discussion y um
$554,000 carry over under the
Improvement fund
great and oh sorry that is a three
readings and Council will over second
very good thank
you um temporary resolution 5-25 a
resolution to increase receipts
appropriate for the unencumbered balance
and amend certificate of other sources
with the county auditor in the
Wastewater replacement and Improvement
fund 6023 again in coming from water
water pollution control councilman Wing
yes thank you uh this is the second
annual piece this evening uh
$240,000 this is a fund to fund transfer
into the Wastewater replacement
Improvement fund the 623 fund okay um
that'll also be three readings and uh
councilman alss will be my second yes
very good thank you any
questions um temporary resolution 6-25 a
resolution to amend the certificate of
Appropriations with the county auditor
appropriate from the unencumbered
balance increased receipts and complete
a fund transfer in the Wastewater fund
64 and in the Wastewater utility Reserve
fund
6029 and coming again from the water uh
water pollution control committee
councilman yes thank you Mr chairman uh
our our third annual piece this evening
um uh this is a $2 million transfer and
and the purpose of this is to be uh
within requirements of our uh Pond
Covenant to keep up the pond rating
right so um that'll also be three
readings and Council tin will be my
second perfect thank
you uh temporary resolution 7-25 a
resolution to
amend 2025 appropriation budgets and
amend the certificate of Appropriations
with the county auditor uh obviously
coming from finance committee uh
and auditor Nettles um yes this is a uh
2025 budget cleanup piece as I was going
through and double-checking the budget
um that Council passed versus the
2025 uh revenue and then the carryer
cash brought over from 2024 I noticed
some funds that two of them that were
going to be over budgeted and two that
didn't have enough budgeted that I'm
required to have budgeted so the first
two uh the police and fires pension fund
and the uh local fiscal recovery I paid
out those funds at the end of in
December 2024 but I failed to amend
during that time frame of all that
budget um uh the final budget to lower
those budgets so now I'm over budgeted
with the county auditor Appropriations
being more than my actual cash so I have
to bring those down the other two um we
have more money in the fund then is
budgeted but I have to be dollar for
dooll um we had some interest being paid
paid into the bond retirement fund that
has to be budgeted to go against a
principal debt payment um in that fund
and in the escrow fund the rounding in
the analytic software rounded me down 15
cents so we've got esro cash for
construction projects that is um waiting
and if we have to have a draw or payout
for those finished um water Wastewater
construction projects I have to have I'm
shy by 15 cents so I have to budget and
amend that to match the cash
I know it's hard to Fathom that some
these other got to balance everything
and I appreciate you Pro State out it
you got to reconcile everything um and
you're looking for suspension this can
go through Reading oh three readings
okay this can go through Reading I'm
just used to that suspension word okay
thank you we'll do three readings and uh
Council M you'll be my second thank
you next we have temporary resolution
8-2 25 a resolution to set a 2025
revenue and expense budget in the storm
water utility utility Reserve fund uh
6019 amend the certificate with the
county auditor and authorize the then
and now certificates for payment of
bills uh again coming from finance
committee and um I'm going to call who's
going to discuss that
I wasn't make sure Nixon's not back
there I could see no he's not sorry and
I I didn't know uh the other pieces
sorry councilman Wing I couldn't speak
to the other pieces earlier um but this
one I can so this piece uh
8-25 deals with uh Appropriations uh
then now certificates Etc in the uh 619
fund which is the storm water utility
Reserve fund this uh and the piece that
follows which covers the other
Improvement funds for the Water
Resources um uh departments
um is an annual piece we do every year
uh that appropriates the funds that we
have left over from last year and allows
us to you know keep paying our bills so
um U again I'm happy to answer any
questions um like I said this is an
annual piece we've T done for as long as
I can remember done it this way outside
of the typical budgeting uh process at
the end of the year um and again uh
since we are waiting on invoices to pay
our vendors we do are hoping we can get
the um suspension and have it approved
in one reading
so you have funds carried over from last
year is that correct yes we have unspent
funds and all these Improvement accounts
um and this is basically reappropriate
what we currently have and um including
the funds we expect to um um transfer in
from other like for example my uh in my
storm water fund here I will um transfer
funds from my 66 fund and that's been
budgeted uh and those will go into the
16/19 to utilize for improvements um
either this year or in future years yeah
it just seems as we do the budget each
year in a pass it in December and work
through through the fall we know we're
going to have carryovers why not
encumber that uh through the first of
the year then we don't have to have this
legislation sure yeah I uh honestly that
yeah I I I'm sorry I can't say I can't
speak eloquently about that or um have
insight into that this is something
that's been done again for as long as I
can remember um I don't know if anybody
else here has any insight into why it's
done that way I think just the nature of
the the funds and um where we have large
dollar amounts and um we have grants
involved and whatnot um and um sometimes
things are tight we we need to know
exactly what we have and if we did it to
the budget process we wouldn't have that
uh at the end of the year um because
that's approved before we've made all
expenditures so um again that's my best
guess but I'm sorry councilman I I can't
address as to why that's historically
been done that way
yes and I can't speak to that either
historically why it was done that way
but auditor Nettles and I were talking
about this today looking at the
different funds and restrictions and we
are going to look and see if there's a
way for us to encumber those on a
purchase order to carry over into 2026
to see if we can avoid doing this
legislation next year yeah I I think
make it cleaner we've got the money we
don't have to worry about you got a bill
waiting be paid or several bills W need
to be paid and I appreciate we have to
suspend but on the same token it it kind
of maybe cleans it up a little bit when
I say cleanup maybe January February
March you'll have a cleanup piece when
you have a better handle on exactly what
your carryovers are uh and unspent funds
so maybe we can work on that perhaps
yeah I don't I don't have any opposition
um like I said this is like I said when
I came into my position store Min
manager this is the way things have been
done so I'm kind of following in that
regard but I'm not unopposed um to or
not opposed rather to you know doing
things different if Council SE it or
other members of administration so
yeah and I just want to add as as I I do
need suspension on these pieces that are
setting the budgets in these Improvement
funds because we've already had owda
come to the bank and take the debt
payments out on January 3rd so I cannot
justify those payments with an expense
transaction in my system to balance to
the treasurer until these are passed so
I have to have the budget in order to
make those transactions so these are
setting the 2025 budget expense budget
in those accounts those funds so I have
to have that to make good a uh uh
payment that was taken on January 3rd
for the owda payments long as you didn't
overdraws uh try not to no there's more
than enough money in there to cover that
yes there's money but I just have to
that's a perfect example why we should
appropriate the money in the prior year
so we don't have to get into some I hate
when I was Treasure I hatte of people
taking money directly out of our
checking account without our Authority
so right very good I appreciate that and
temporary resolution U
925 yeah again same thing this just
covers the water and waste water
Improvement funds which are 626 627 629
and 6030 right very good any questions
other questions of
councel thank you y thank you and we
will be suspending uh each of those and
uh councilman Su you'll do the uh second
for me on 92 uh
9:25 and uh Council ALS you'll do the
second for me on resolution
825 thank
you council member council member
wolfinger on both of those pieces of
legislation since they're together and
in the same committee I was informed by
the law director that we only need to do
one motion to suspend for both so we can
just mention both of those and do a
motion to suspend and then move to
regular meeting or regular reading of
each piece of legislation that' be great
mind me because I'll probably forget
between now and then we'll
do uh temporary resolution 10-25 a
resolution stating the services to be
provided by the municipal Corporation to
Annex territory a blue label packaging
for the expedited type two annexation of
partial numbers
60800 027
00611 0000 0 consisting of
5.08 plus or minus acres in Pleasant
Town f Pleasant Township and to declar
an emergency uh this is coming from
Economic Development Committee
councilman
who thank you um this piece just is a
statement um that we have to provide
them within 20 days of the services that
we're going to provide through the anx
um it needs suspended because of the
20-day time frame okay think that's it
law director any further comments on
that
we've seen it we've all seen it before
and this is an exception to the rule
that we have to comply to the higher
Revised
Code thank you uh no other resolutions
to come before uh ordinances temporary
ordinance
1-25 an ordinance to accept the final
plant for the Fairfield Park Development
coming from code enforcement and zoning
committee uh councilman
suy thank you chairman this will be the
the first of three readings and we have
chazel and Carter here
to discuss this
legislation good evening everyone um so
temporary ordinance 125 is just asking
for your acceptance of the final plat
for fairf Park development uh the
Planning Commission did pass this last
month I did send around uh kind of an
explanation of what you were looking at
for the plat so if you have any
questions feel free to ask and I also
have Joe Thomas here from Metro to give
you just a brief um explanation on the
project good evening again Joe Thomas
I'm with Metro development we're the
actual owner and developer of Airfield
Park it is a 240 apartment unit complex
roughly on 12 acres it's a mixture of
one two and three bedrooms um location
is North Columbus Street in hubard drive
right next to the 84 Lumber uh andjon to
two two car
dealerships and then there's a small
roundabout with a couple business there
on HUB Drive um we also are
participating in the Citywide CRA so
there will be affordability component to
this development and I'm here to answer
any questions thank
you any question
questions did by chance you bring any
like artistic prints or anything I'm
curious of what the we this is going to
look like I'm sorry I did not um I
apologize we went through a resoning
process on this property and uh just to
give it I guess I can give you a visual
explanation but it's uh they're three
story Breezeway apartments with a
mixture of a stone Shake siding and
horizontal sighting and some board and
Baton uh with Associated garages uh with
the development as well
so here t i we're we're trying to
basically address a there's a
Subdivision plat that was on two
commercial lots that we purchased we're
going to Simply Be combining those lots
with the larger commercial lot that we
purchase as well so we're um you know
here for the plat process but I
apologize for not bringing illustrations
for you and then access to the complex
it's that I understand there's going to
be two entrances correct one on hubber
drive and one on North Columbus Street
we'll have a community center at the
entrance to North Columbus Street and
there's 10 Associated apartment
buildings uh and then some Associated
garages as
well okay and there's I guess there's
going to be a turn lane built on
Columbus Street that's
correct what direction will that be
going uh there'll be well it'll be a
left-and turn line into the complex so
okay and that's part actually in the
county still okay be a county project
okay gotcha thank you that's all
councilman Su we have exterior
elevations that went to Planning
Commission and we can provide you with
those if you'd like to see them I didn't
see them yep thank
you any other
questions and um your second
is Elena y okay thank you and three
readings three okay perfect thank
you uh next item is temporary res
temporary ordinance 2-25 an ordinance to
amend permanent ordinance
54-24 to end a declare an emergency
coming from finance committee
um
and
is Alita here she's not I apologize she
thought that she I've been texting with
her she thought that she had to come to
the um actual council meeting of the
whole and not Finance she'll be here in
about 15 minutes so if you wanted to
keep discussing everything on the list
and do the departmental update hopefully
she'll be here before you're done with
your finance committee meeting thank you
yep appreciate it
yep moving on to Temporary ordinance
3-25 an ordinance to repeal ler codified
ordinance part 7 business regulations
codes chapters 711 715 721 731 785 and
791 of the cified ordinance of the city
of Lancaster coming from law committee
and uh councilman CH yes thank you um
this is legislation to repeal six
unneeded or obsolete ordinances that are
included in the business Regulation Code
um they were passed between the 50s and
80 1950s and 1980s and relate to
businesses no longer exist or need
enforced uh we can go three readings and
Mr bisek is my second
very good any questions or further
comments thank you temporary ordinance
4-25 an ordinance to amend permanent
ordinance
54-24 uh to authorize the service safety
director to enter into a lease contract
with the Fairfield County Commissioners
for the second floor of the City Annex
Building 123 East Chestnut Street for
juvenile court services uh coming from
the administrative Services committee uh
councilman lber uh thank you Mr chair I
think this is just to amend a three-year
lease to a one-year lease is that
correct okay that's correct yeah uh we
discussed this at our December meeting
and we're talking about a three-year
lease to uh the county for the second
floor of the City Annex Building and we
have since decided just to make that a
one-year lease so that's all this is and
those there an increase in a rent of
3% uh yes so the previous year's lease
okay yep I know we had disc quite a bit
of discussion last time we talked about
in December any other comments questions
from
Council regarding this and if you'd be
so kind as being my second if I don't
forget we're good thank you councilman
wolfinger yes is there any way that we
could respectfully request suspension on
this since it was previously approved in
December um in order for us to enter
into this lease we would need to approve
it from city council and then it also
has to be approved through the County
Commissioners once we approve it and we
are currently operating without a lease
agreement because ours expired in
December so if there's any way to
respectfully request suspension or if
not maybe at least two readings instead
of three readings we would be ever so
grateful you would be well they have a
council they have a commissioner's
meeting tomorrow morning so maybe you'd
like to take it up is there any
objection from Council to uh suspend
second and
third so be it thank you thank you
you're
welcome uh no other ordinances to come
before Council uh uh let's get into
departmental updates
good evening Council um service director
Woody asked me to give you a little
update on what our Department's been
doing for the last seven days 8 Days
nine days somewhere in there um if you
haven't been outside your house in last
week you know it snowed so um a little
bit about what we've been doing um I put
together a little map of what uh our
routes look like and a little bit of
data about the two storms we we handled
um the first storm came about a week ago
Sunday um on the 6th the 5th um when the
weathermen all started getting all
excited the week before that we started
watching the news and and uh monitoring
things and then sure enough Sunday
rolled in and we actually got what they
predicted so we called crws in at 4:00
on Sunday and we worked them 247 until
midnight on Tuesday going into
Wednesday um a little bit about that
event uh we received between four and
six inches of snow depending on what
part of town you were in and uh in that
event as you can see we used 510 tons of
salt our current salt per ton cost this
year is
$69
65 so we spread about 35 a little over
$35,000 worth of salt and we also added
to that uh a brine mixture which we
pre-wet the salt with as it comes out of
the trucks and we also use it for
brining applications ahead of the storm
which we actually were able to do
because it did not rain prior to the
event so we actually used 15,600 gallons
of that that only cost us 46 cents a
gallon to make so between those two
types of product we spent
$442,000 applying salt and
brine um as you note here I we we
actually have 10 trucks available to
push now and salt we actually have eight
dedicated routes which are indicated on
the map that I've given to
you the dark lines are actually
representative of those
maps and just to give you a little uh
rundown on that is when we go out and
start start our snow and ice
operations those are the what we call
the main routes those are the routes we
hit first those are the routes we make
sure our clear as it is snowing until
until the snow is is pretty much done
coming down we will stay on those
routes I've broken them down they are
color coded and I've broken down how
many Lane miles each each of those
routes is and for you those who don't
know what a lane mile is a lane mile is
when you drive One Direction and one
lane so for instance our route one which
is our West Side route
is 22.6 Lane miles so one driver has to
drive that many Lane miles to cover that
route um in that event alone we had uh
823 manh hours doing that one event and
we had a total driven miles of just over
5,000 miles um that's about 559 miles
each one of those trucks drove in that
56-hour period
then Along came a little skiff event
last Friday into Saturday morning that
was a quick one it was only one to three
inches but it snowed all night the guys
were in they were pretty much on the
main routes all night um so we worked
them to get that cleaned up and then uh
they were able to move into the
residentials so when we call guys in we
have we only have 20 guys in the
department right now that can or 21 guys
that can come in and push now so we have
uh 10 on one shift 11 on the other
there's a mechanic on each one of those
shifts so they technically don't drive a
route but uh they can if if need be with
one of the extra
trucks at this point we have an
alternate route who can assist he gets
out and helps the bigger trucks in the
cacs where they can't get um that's not
really a dedicated route he's CU he's
all over the place so we might have uh
11 guys on the road any given one given
time but eight of these are dedicated to
these routes alone once we get these
main routes open and
we're confident that we don't need to be
throwing any more salt at them these uh
these guys will team up into pairs of uh
two and they start getting into
residentials our main goal in
residentials CU that's probably where
your complaints are going to come from
your constituents is I haven't seen a
plow in front of my house
well you
will technically what we try to do is we
get at least one pass into a residential
one pass out at least to get things open
up and then we start pushing things back
to the curb so our our strategy is to to
do that but parked cars and people
driving around kind of make it difficult
sometimes so if we don't get to your
house right away we will eventually all
of our trucks are monitored with the
same Sam sah AVL system so we know where
they are at any given time so we can
pull it up on a on a map and we can
actually tell when a truck passed a
certain address at what time they passed
it and whether or not the salt spinner
was on so if there's any if there if
there's ever any any doubt anybody has
any concerns you can get a hold of me or
uh one of my guys in the office and we
can we can verify that yes we have
driven all 400 miles of our streets um
Carrie rode around one night with with
the guys uh councilwoman hoop came in
she got to ride around get a little bit
of an education and any of anybody out
there who wants to ride around and look
at the snowflakes as they come down give
me a
call so um pretty much that's it you
might get a call about a mailbox yes we
will hit a mailbox now and then um
mailboxes are required to have the door
the front of the mailbox one foot behind
the face of the curb and every now and
then we will jump a curb especially when
the snow gets a little deep and we will
take it out and we will replace those
but if your mailbox is not installed
properly you may not get it replaced
right away and there's always uh the law
director's office you can contact her if
you want to if the resident wants
to file a claim file a claim and uh
that'll come back to me and we'll we'll
if we can determine that the mailbox was
installed properly we will replace it if
it's a fancy one it's got bricks all
around it you won't get that back but
you will get a functioning mailbox
back any
questions of
councel just just a thank you all right
thank you very much forgive me I was
taking notes you might have mentioned
this how's our inventory of salt for the
balance of the Year well we started with
uh about 3,400 tons and we've used a
total of 753 so so we're looking real
good right now um we'll get we'll get in
about a month we'll probably order our
first load from OD do or from our vendor
through OD do so right but
we're we're not we're not good news just
wasting it so we're we're doing good
good thank you all right appreciate
it you going to
talk be sad
good evening members of council thank
you for the opportunity to let me
address you tonight um every year we do
a we publicize an annual report
typically at the beginning of February
just uh compiling data in statistics at
the police department uh however those
data and statistics are pretty much
useless if you're not measuring outcomes
and and doing something with the data so
what I wanted to do is uh one promise
that we're still on track and on task to
put that annual report out by the
beginning of February um but I want to
give you a broad overview and rundown of
some of the more important data uh that
you would be interested in and your
constituents would be interested in here
tonight um three things that I typically
hear the most from Council Members or uh
citizens in general have to do with
hiring Community engagement crime
suppression uh what we're doing about
certain crimes uh Etc Hiring Our
detective Bureau and background
investigators continue to have their
pedal on medal they've hired uh or at
least vetted five sworn officers through
the process last year so we're at 77 out
of 79 authorized officers uh so we're in
really good shape there we're very close
to being at fully staffed with uh 25
coming we're expecting about five to six
retirements so we'll continue to have to
keep our focus on hiring uh but I've
said it before you guys have allowed us
the ability to to hire a good quality
human being first as opposed to a piece
of paper saying somebody's certified and
they've done the job before
I'd much rather just have a good human
being first and so that's who we
continue to hire and uh we've done
really well with that and very
appreciative of that um Community
engagement despite the focus on Hiring
Our Community Services Unit and officers
SWAT officers detective Bureau um just
everybody in general all the staff
dispatchers at the PD they went to over
160 community events last year that's
darn near uh an event every couple few
days which is pretty amazing so they're
out there embedded in the community
that's everything from craze training
workplace violence training um Safety
Town youth uh educational programs so
they're out there in the community
that's um probably triple what we were
doing a few years ago and so they're
really really breaking their back to get
out there and be involved in the
community and I think that's paying
dividends the uh bread and butter of the
annual report typically is just the
crime suppression numbers and the the uh
call for service data sweet again for
the second year in a row are going to
push 70 calls for service 70,000 calls
for service um per year to put that in
perspective a few years ago we were
hovering around the 50 to 55,000 range
um so the proactivity is skyrocketed
along with the calls for service uh this
population just tends to get busier and
busier and our officers are are working
very hard so 70,000 calls for service
again this
year um the the two major areas that I
get asked about the most our quality of
life so for instance burglaries and
traffic enforcement um there's some
pretty encouraging numbers that you'll
see that I want to report tonight for
instance our burglary numbers which
affects every resident in this community
we're still hovering in the 160 to 180
uh burglaries per year range um I
believe mayor McDaniel and previous
Chief McDaniel can attest that we used
to average about a burglary a year we're
around 350 to 400 burglaries a year
we're hovering around the $160 180 range
I again this year will not be as
confident to say what directive is
actually bringing that number down I can
say the numbers come sharply down in the
last couple years but to give some
reference on what the officers are doing
out there um we have two main categories
that we that we call Proactive measures
to to fight burglary robbery um crimes
of violence Etc and those are area
watches and business checks those are
just proactive measures of officers
being out in the neighborhoods looking
at problem before they start listening
to community members and being in the
area if they call if something's
happening so for instance in 24 we ran
14,000 area watches we used to average
about 3,000 area watches a year we did
14,000 last year business checks we did
17,000 we used to average about
4,500 um and in turn I believe those
burglary numbers came down uh cut in
half also the um the traffic enforcement
I think it's a fairly common theme uh my
family included sometimes to say that
you know we're not out there doing as
much traffic enforcement as we should
I'm sure you guys hear the same the same
thing um I will die on that Hill the
officers break their back to do quality
traffic enforcement they don't pull
people over for too much window 10 or
not using a tur signal they do accident
causing violations um and for point of
reference on the frequency of that we
did
4500 uh traffic stop measures last year
typically um going back to 22 and prior
we were running about 2500 so we've
almost doubled the amount of traffic
enforcement and these numbers are very
encouraging here our o auto accidents
have gone down on average from 1,000 to
1100 a year last year we went to
424 um auto accident with injury we were
averaging around 300 to 400 a year 398 a
couple years prior we had 89 last year
so I can confidently say a lot of that
targeted enforcement is working um I
can't promise you a magic bean every
year and say if we do the exact same
thing we'll have these numbers again but
these officers are working very very
hard to bring these numbers down and now
we have two to three years of
consistency of these numbers being down
so I'm very proud of the work they're
doing um they make my job very very very
easy when they're outo out there doing
uh what the public wants them to do a
couple other categories I'll mention
really quick uh person in crisis that
continues to be
um a call a mental health call that we
see creeping up again last year was no
stranger to that we had 384 calls for
service involving Persona crisis um and
then our directive Patrol unit had a its
first full year of operation last year
with a full staff they are supposed to
have five people in that unit again
that's a unit that doesn't respond to
calls for service they respond to
Quality of Life issues and things that
the citizens complain on they typically
had around three full-time officers
working in that last year it's supposed
to consist of three canine officers and
two dedicated non- canine officers
because of an injury and a promotion we
only had about three but the numbers are
going to blow your socks off with that
unit uh they worked 757 days last year
combined with the three officers they
issued 297 citations for accident
causing violations and problem area
violations they had 34 K9 deployments
they took 70 guns off the street out of
three officers that's more guns off the
street than our entire Patrol Division
combined um 230 gram of fentanyl were
seiz 690 gram of methampetamine were
seized 5 550 grams of other drugs such
as cocaine and heroin were seized off
the streets to give you some reference
there's 453 grams in a pound they're
taking pounds of drugs off the street um
in addition to that Patrol calls which
often get backed up and we have issues
with Staffing sometimes on patrol calls
they respond resped to 95 Patrol
assistance calls meaning that that's not
a backup officer that had to come out of
the patrol rotation that directed Patrol
unit went and backed up uh a patrol
officer on a call they deployed 206
warrants so they wrote paper on 206
either objects or residences and carried
those out had 184 felony charges and 155
misdemeanor charges so again that's just
a broad overview of the activity but uh
that unit is invaluable uh the officers
are invaluable the dispatchers have done
a phenomenal job with what they've been
given so very proud of that group of
people over there despite the obstacles
that they face if you have any questions
I'd be more than happy to answer but I
just wanted to give you a brief rundown
being it's the first meeting of the
year not a not a question but just want
to say thank you to the men and women of
the police department for all you do for
the city thank you those are great
numbers okay thank you appreciate it
very much uh anybody else wish to there
you go another
Chief good evening my update tonight is
in regards to our EMS building
program about three weeks ago our new
company medic account started actively
billing um for our transports it's been
a long time a lot of work it seemed like
a a mountain of paperwork a lot of
collaboration from a lot of the city
departments and a lot of other agencies
to get this up and running um so I am
pleased to say that our new companies up
um billing as they should um another
thing that we realized was going on
probably about 3 months ago we started
getting phone calls from residents um we
weren't aware that change Healthcare our
previous billing partner who had for um
little history back in February of 2024
had a breach stopped all activity um EMS
billing Revenue went flat after February
um and they started building our
residents again um we weren't aware of
that till we received an invoice and
residents were calling us they were very
confused because past practice for the
last 20 years is a resident who's
transported by lanaster fire to the
hospital um our billing company builds
their insurance company or Medicare they
receive a payment sometimes there's a
balance between what was charged and
what was paid um residents were never
supposed to receive a bill for that um
they did not follow that pass practice
they started sending those bills out so
our office I know City Hall um some
other agencies are receiving some um
confusing phone calls for the citizens
um if anybody's listening or you get any
phone calls for constituents um my
advice is to tell them to disregard
those bills just like everybody else has
for the last two decades um hopefully
this won't last much longer they do have
a 90-day windown period um October 28th
or 2024 is the last date of service that
U change Healthcare will be billing for
they have a 90-day wind down so it'll be
roughly at the end of January when they
should cease and stop all the billing um
and moving forward medic account um who
has much better customer customer
service and does respond to phone calls
and emails um they are taking over for
us so is there any questions on EMS
billing or anything with the fire
department just thank you for supporting
our residence Chief you're welcome thank
you
okay any other departmental
updates am I allowed to give an update
absolutely we're here all night so I
have just a couple updates that I wanted
to make uh Council aware of and that is
if you weren't aware our fire chief uh
Steve mathin did retire after over 30
years of service with the city of
Lancaster he refused to let us give him
public acknowledgement or a farewell
party so I am doing this now hoping that
he's watching because he can't stop me
uh he did a great job and we are truly
thankful for all of his years of service
um so we are working with the Civil
Service Commission to go through the
process of hiring a new fire chief um so
in the interim we do have acting Chief
Slade Schultz and so thank you uh chief
for all of all that you've done
in the interim um I also wanted to let
you know that uh an update on the city
hall project we are still on target for
the city hall renovation project the
exterior of City Hall uh the architect
schoie Caldwell uh is presenting their
plans to the historic commission later
this week and once that's approved
hopefully approved um then we'll be able
to finalize specs and get it out to bid
so again we're hoping to start work this
spring on City Hall um I also wanted to
let you know I know that I saw several
of you downtown for the ball uh drop
that is done by ddl I know Amanda's out
here somewhere I think uh who and
partnering with the Lancaster Parks
Department who does an amazing job with
this Pro with with the event um but we
couldn't do it without interface video
as well helping and I wanted to just
share with you because I thought this
was very interesting uh interface sent
me an email saying that we had had
viewers in 22 States and three countries
that were watching it live in Lancaster
Ohio so a huge thanks to Amanda and ddl
our parks department and interface video
for broadcasting that and allowing 22
States and three countries to watch our
live broadcast in our downtown Lancaster
so I thought that was very interesting
and wanted to share that all with you
and then my final would be uh just a
huge thanks to all of our city
departments um with the inclement
weather that we just experienced a
little bit more than we're typically
used to or that we usually get at one
time I will say police and fire were
obviously very busy dealing with
accidents related to inclement weather
you already heard uh superintendent
Deets talking about working around the
clock uh to try and clear our streets uh
our water department you know they got
called out for some water leaks and they
had to do this in the snow and the
freezing cold fixing water leaks and
they were called out in the evening
um so again huge thanks to all of our
departments um but I also wanted to just
kind of throw out there thanks to all
the residents that cleared their
sidewalks um that's a huge help as well
because we do have a lot of residents
that have mobility issues um and so
clearing sidewalks is a huge help so
thanks to the residents that were able
to assist in clean sidewalks as well but
I also kind of wanted to throw out that
if we do have residents that don't have
the ability to clear their sidewalks uh
call us at City Hall we have a lot of
volunteer groups that contact me
specifically asking if anybody needs
help clearing sidewalks and I'm more to
help I'm more than happy to help make
that connection for residents if they do
need assistance cleaning sidewalks in
the
future and that's my update well thank
you mayor would you like to make an
update I think everybody else is pretty
much
covered JY thank you appreciate it very
much um I assume Noone else in the
audience from the city as a to say
perfect thank you um moving on to
tonight's meeting prep um president
councilman wolfinger did you see that uh
the clerk of court came in she might
have snuck in okay I just want to make
sure you saw she was here yeah she's on
probation right now oh
okay but thank you I appreciate that we
have no um special updates for tonight's
meeting thank
you and any other items for
finance I Hear
n and
we have a guest valita come on
up and we are going to
discuss temporary ordinance number uh
225 an ordinance to amend perent
ordinance
54-24 and declare an emergency uh coming
from finance committee and if you could
fill into your needs sure sure um when
the temporary ordinance was put in place
um um prior to the budget being passed I
had my staff the number is the same just
for the record um I'm not adding any
staff it's just a move within my staff I
had that had given that for the
council's um consideration when we were
P when you were passing the budget and
at that time all of those numbers made
sense it all lined up at that time I was
also in the process just for some
background I have two employees in my
office who are both beyond their 30th
year um with the City and in in the
clerk's office um I started the process
of thinking forward in a 5 to sevene
plan as to who it is that takes the
place of those people one of those um
employees is my chief deputy and she's
been the chief Deputy for a she preceded
me um in the office as the chief Deputy
the other is what I deem my
administrative Deputy clerk um the two
of them as you can imagine with 30 years
of experience have a wealth of knowledge
that is not easily replaced so I've
started the process of planning who in
my office it seems will be the people
who will step into those roles um and it
it's not an easy role to step into
either one of them but in the meantime
I've also been made aware if you look at
the change that I'm asking for the the
change is taking one person who at that
time was in the C range on my budget and
I'm asking to add that person to the E
range because I have um outside of my
chief Deputy my administrative Deputy
everyone else in my office is a deputy
clerk with the exception of three
positions that I call supervisors within
the Civil the criminal and the Traffic
Division um I had someone in a
supervisory role in the Traffic Division
and it came to my attention um the week
before Christmas that that person is
very actively seeking employment
elsewhere um so when I'm looking at a 5
to sevene plan she ceases to be a plan
in 5 to seven years when I know that she
doesn't intend to stay in my office so
there is someone who I would like to
move into that position without harming
the person that had held that position
um I want to put this person in because
she has been a part of my plan going
forward very specifically looking at my
chief Deputy position and the roles that
she takes care of in my office and this
person that I'm asking to be bumped from
a c to an F is absolutely already
starting to learn some of the book
keeping the jury duty um work that my
chief Deputy currently does so that is
why I'm asking for just a change not
again not in the number of employees
that I have just that I have I had six
in the C range one in the e- range I'm
asking that the one person from the C
range be bumped to a to an um I'm sorry
an e range because she is going to be in
a supervisory position not my chief
Deputy yet just in a supervisory role
so okay uh questions of council
back to you thank
you your
second okay uh councilman alss you'll be
my second yes and one reading suspension
as we've talked
before
um and that is everything we needed to
discuss and I would entertain a
motion so
Mo
second um I I need to do a recall did
you say roll call vote on this no I do
not okay all those in favor please
second say I I do and we are
dismissed the regular meeting of
Lancaster City Council will commence
promptly at 7 p.m.
seem
[Music]
the Frankie Smith Funeral Home en
cremator in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community feel free to give us a
call at
0652 stop in and see us at either of our
two locations 405 North Columbus Street
in Lancaster and 207 South Main Street
in Baltimore respect for tradition
regard for
[Music]
change great automotive service is just
around the corner at the Buckey family
of dealerships whether it's Buckeye
Nissan and Hillyard Georgesville Nissan
at the Georgesville Auto Mall Buckeye
Honda of Lancaster Buckeye Toyota of
Lancaster or Buckeye Collision Center in
hilard team Buckeye Services all makes
and models at each location utilizing
modern practices with hundreds of years
of experience giving you peace of mind
that's how we
[Music]
Buckeye
e
e e
[Music]
please rise if you are able and join me
in a moment of
prayer God grant us the serenity to
accept the things that we cannot change
the courage to change the things we can
and finally the wisdom to know the
difference
I now call the January 13th 2025
Lancaster City council meeting to order
please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge aliance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for it stands one nation
God indivisible with liy and justice for
all
please call the
role Mr Al here sorry Mr bisj here Mrs C
here Mrs hoop here Mr lenberg here Mr
Skov here M tener here Mr suy here Mr
Wing here and Mr wolfinger yes here
please let the record reflect that all
10 members of Lancaster City Council are
present this evening um and I just
remind everybody to please turn on your
microphones for purposes of the regular
meeting we'll now move to the reading
and disposal of the
journal regular meeting minutes dated
December 9th 2024 and special meeting
minutes December 23rd
2024 Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and file the journal
second we have a motion a second to
receive and file the journal all those
in favor please signify by saying I I
all those post same sign reports of City
officials email dated January 3rd 2025
regarding 2024 mandated reporting of
seized money accounts submitted by
police chief Snider email data January
2nd 2025 regarding
2025 VIP purchase order submitted by
auditor Nettles email dated December
31st 2024 regarding deposit of public
money City policy submitted by auditor
Nettles email dated December 31st 2024
regarding 2025 Planning Commission
planning packets submitted by city
planner Carter email dated December 27th
2024 regarding Cemetery rules updates
submitted by superintendent Deets email
dated December 26 2024 regarding Medical
Healthcare Clinic updates submitted by
HR coordinator Williams series of emails
dated to December 19th 2024 through
December 23rd 2024 council members
Council clerk IT director
star service safety director Woody law
director Hall regarding requests for
special council meeting I'm sorry I did
those all backwards today email data
December 20th 2024 regarding Financial
disclosure statement submitted by Mr Su
Services of emails dated um series of
emails dated January 7th and 8 2025
between city planner commissioner Carter
or chazin Carter and Mr lenberg
regarding final plot for Fairfield Park
email dated January 8th 2025 regarding a
male incident in the Pickerington area
submitted by police chief Nick Snider
email dated January 8th 2025 regarding
income tax December collections report
submitted by Tax Commissioner Emy
Hamilton
Mr President i' like to make a motion to
receive and file the reports of City
officials second we have a motion and
second to receive and file the reports
of City officials all those in favor
please signify by saying I I all those
oppose same sign we now move to
Communications voicemail dated December
13 2024 regarding public hearing being
held January 25th
2025 from John oberly series of emails
dated December 17th 2024 between Melissa
Burns cille Clerk and clerk Scott
regarding Insight on how the city of
Lancaster permanently retains their
ordinances and resolutions voicemail
data December 17 2024 regarding public
hearing being held January 25th
2025 from John McGraw of Mr jj1
LLC um mail received January 7th 2025
regarding liquor license for Red Lobster
number 553 from Ohio Division of liquor
control email data January 8th 2025
regarding ddl and SSD Sid annual
Gathering invitation submitted by Amanda
Everett by downtown destination
Lancaster Mr President I'd like to make
a motion to receive and file the
communications second we have a motion
second to receive and file the
communications all those in favor please
signify by saying
I all those oppose same sign we have no
special presentations and awards this
evening uh do we have any petitions and
memorials no petitions or memorials this
evening we have now reached the time in
the agenda where it is the permission of
vot Voters and taxpayers to address
council do we have anybody who wishes to
address city council this
evening seeing none we will continue
with regular order of business move to
the reports of standing committees
finance committee agenda dated January
13 2025 submitted by Mr
wolfinger Mr President i' like to make a
motion to receive and file the reports
of standing committees second we have a
motion and second to receive and file
the reports of standing committees all
those in favor please signify by saying
I I all those oppos same sign we now
move the reports of special committees
there are no reports of special
committees presented to council this
evening thank you there is no public
hearing scheduled for this evening Mr
President yes
like to go out of the order of business
and make a motion to appoint councilman
Su to
his committee assignments as the chair
of code enforcement and zoning and also
as member of the finance committee and
Safety Committee second we have a motion
the second to um appoint uh our new
council member Mr suy to his committees
all those in favor signify by saying I I
all those oppose same sign thank you
congratulations on your committee
assignments this
evening so we will now move on to the
reading of resolutions for tonight's
meeting beginning with the third reading
of temporary resolution
130-24 a resolution to authorize then
announced certificates for the Community
Development block grant
2073 chip home program fund
2083 in for the Healthy Home Grant 2026
year end 2024 project expenditures
Economic Development Committee Mrs hoops
and Mrs crates council member
hoop
um I just threw a
blank I think we might be no this is an
annual piece it's a then and now to pay
any invoices that will be received in
20125 that were incurred in 2024 okay
we'll take a motion
motion to pass yes I'm sorry so I would
like to make a motion that Council pass
and gross and enter upon the written
record
resolution give me a
second okay
um now I just can't stop laughing um the
temporary resolution
13024 second we have a motion and second
to pass engross and enter upon the
written record tempor resolution
1324 I would ask if there's any
discussion but you've already done that
is there any further discussion from our
counil at this at this time hearing none
please call the RO Mr ALS yes Mr bisj
yes Mrs K yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg
yes Mr skover yes Mr suy yes Miss tener
yes Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes
temporary resolution 13024 passes 10 to
Z we now move to the second reading of
resolutions and there are none this
evening uh we will now be moving into
the uh first reading of resolutions
beginning with temporary resolution
125 um I believe that temporary
resolution 125 and temporary resolution
225 are both going to um be subject to
suspension this evening so council
member cres yes thank you Mr President
want to read yes the clerk will read
both would you like me to read both of
them first and then correct okay um
temporary resolution 125 is a resolution
to authorize City departments to dispose
of the city property no longer needed
via auction or Internet auction in 2025
and to declare an emergency this is law
committee with Mrs CR and Mr bisj and
temporary resolution 225
uh a resolution in support of the Ohio
Municipal League's challenge of AT&T's
tariff application at the Public
Utilities Commission of Ohio and to
declare an emergency again this is law
committee with Mrs Kites and then Mr
wolfinger Mr President I would like to
make a motion that Council suspend its
rules and wave the second and third
readings of resolutions temporarily
numbered 1-25 and
2-25 second we have a motion in a second
to suspend the rules in the way of the
second and third reading of temporary
resolution 12 125 and temporary
resolution resolution 225 is there any
discussion on the motion to suspend yes
thank you um temporary resolution 125 we
are asking for suspension um so that we
can start our internet auctions of
property that's no longer needed and we
need this passed before that can be uh
begun and then also to join a Utilities
Commission action against AT&T's tariff
application thank you any further
discussion hearing none please call the
role Mr ALS yes Mr bisack yes Mrs KES
yes Mrs hoop no Mr lenberg yes Mr Su I
have to abstain because of my current
okay
situation
okay M Mr SC
yes did I get you Mr Miss tener yes Mr
Wing yes and Mr wolfinger
yes motion to suspend passes 8 to one
with one
exstension we would now move to the
third or all the the reading of temp
sorry excuse me you can go now move Mr
President I would like to make a motion
that Council pass Andross and enter upon
the written record resolution
temporarily number 1
25 second a motion second to um pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
temporary resolution 125 any further
discussion no hearing hearing none we
will now move forward with roll call Mr
ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs CRA yes Mrs hoop
yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes Mr
Su yes Miss
tener I'm sorry I that's an obain
for both of them Welling separ no this
is just this is just temporary
resolution 125 so the 225 was an abstain
okay um no you're fine Miss tener yes Mr
Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes so
temporary resolution 125 passes 10 to Z
we will now move to Temporary resolution
225 Mr President I would like to make a
motion that Council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record resolution
temporarily number
2-25 second have a motion second to pass
and gross enter upon the written record
temporary resolution
225 hearing no discussion please call
the rooll Mr alss yes Mr bis yes Mrs CR
yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr
skover yes Mr Sully you're abstaining
Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes temporary resolution
passes temporary resolution 225 passes 9
to zero with one abstention now move on
to the reading of temporary resolution
325 an ordinance to repeal Lancaster
codified ordinance
[Music]
part oh on ordinance I apologize wrong
side okay a resolution to authorize the
Lancaster Police Department to apply for
the 2025 2026 drug use prevention
Grant um Safety Committee Mr bisj and Mr
Sul council member bisj thank you Mr
President I move that Council suspend
its rules and wave the second and third
reading for temporary resolution
3-25 second have motion second to
suspend the rules and wave the second
and third reading of temporary
resolution 325 any discussion not at
this time Mr President thank you hearing
no further discussion please call the
roll on the motion to suspend Mr alss
yes Mr bisj yes Mrs K yes Mrs hoop no Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes Mr Su yes Miss
tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger
yes motion to suspend passes 9 to one
council member bisj thank you Mr
President I move that Council passing
gross and enter upon the rent record
temporary resolution
3-25 we have a motion second to pass and
enter upon the written record temporary
resolution 3 25 any further discussion
council member bisj thank you Mr
President the only thing to add is that
this is a regular piece of legislation
that the police department um asks for
every year this is to apply for money
for the D program for the 2025 2026 year
thank you any further
discussion please call and roll Mr ALS
yes Mr bisack yes Mrs CR yes Mrs hoop
yes Mr lenberg yes Mr scooter yes Mr Su
yes M tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr woler
yes temporary resolution 325 passes 10
to
zero now move on to Temporary resolution
425 a resolution to appropriate from the
own incomer balance amend the
certificate of Appropriations with the
county auditor in the Wastewater
replacement and Improvement fund 6023
and authorize the issuance of a then and
now certificates for payments of bills
water water pollution committee and Mr
wing with Mrs Tiner council member Wing
yes thank you Mr President this will be
the first of three readings first of
three readings on temporary resolution
425 temporary resolution 525 a
resolution to increase appr and
appropriate from the UN increased
receips appropriate from the
unencumbered balance and to amend the
certificate of other sources with the
county auditor in the Wastewater
replacement and Improvement fund
6023 this is with water water pollution
committee Mr Wing and Mr alss council
member Wing first of three readings
please first of three readings on
temporary resolution 525 temporary
resolution
625 a resolution to amend the
certificate of Appropriations with the
county auditor appropriate from the
unencumbered balance increase receipts
and complete a fund transfer in the
Wastewater fund
6004 and in the Wastewater utility
Reserve fund
6029 water um water pollution committee
Mr Wing and Miss tener council member
Wing first of three readings first of
three readings on temporary resolution
625 temporary resolution
725 a resolution to amend 2025
appropriation budgets and amend the
certificate of Appropriations with the
county auditor this is through finance
committee Mr wolfinger and Mr Sully
council member wolfinger first of three
readings please first of three readings
on temporary resolution
725 temporary resolution 82
a resolution to set a 2025 revenue and
expense budget in the storm water
utility Reserve
6019 amend the certificate amend their
certificates with the county of auditor
and authorize then announce certificates
for pay payments of bills this is
through finance committee Mr wolfinger
and Mr alss um and we also can take I
believe these are both going for
suspension we can also do temporary
resolution 925 for purposes of
suspension okay temporary resolution
9-25 a resolution to set a 2025 revenue
and expense budget in the water
construction fund 6026 water utility
Reserve fund 6027 Wastewater utility
Reserve fund 6029 and Wastewater
construction fund
6030 amend the certificates with the
county auditor and authorize then an now
certificates for payments of bills and
once again through finance committee Mr
wolfinger and Mr Sully council member
wolfinger Mr President I'd like to make
a motion that Council suspends suspense
its rules and waves the second and third
readings of temporary
resolutions seven or 8-25 and
9-25
second we can take one second thank you
good thank you um any discussion council
member wolfinger
um no as we discussed in finance
committee both of these are dealing with
budget adjustments and setting the
budget for uh
2025 thank you hearing no further
discussion please call the role on the
Motions to suspend 825 and temporary
resolution 925 Mr ALS yes Mr bisat yes
Mrs KES yes Mrs hoop yes Mr luberg yes
Mr skover yes Mr Su yes Miss tener yes
Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes motion
to suspend the rules and wave the second
third reading of temporary resolution
825 and 925 P 10 to zero council member
wolfinger uh Mr President I'd like to
make a motion that Council pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
temporary resolution
8-25 second we have a motion second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution 825
any further discussion no further
discussion thank you
um please call the RO Mr ALS Mr bisj yes
Mrs CH yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes
Mr skover yes Mr Sully yes Miss tener
yes Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes
motion to pass engross an enter upon the
written record temporary resolution 825
passes 10 to zero temporary resolution
925 Mr oh sorry council member right
okay I didn't want to walk on you sorry
Mr President I'd like to make a motion
the council pass and gross and enter
upon the written record temporary
resolution
9-25 Mr s second thank you we have a
motion a second to pass Congress enter
upon the written record temporary
resolution 925 any further discussion no
please call the rooll Mr ALS yes Mr Bish
yes Mrs KES yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg
yes Mr skover yes Mr Su yes Miss tener
yes Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes
motion to pass and gross and enter upon
the written record temporary resolution
925 passes 10 to zero we now move to
Temporary resolution 1025 a resolution
stating the services to be provided by
the municipal Corporation to Annex
territory of blue label packaging
company for the
expedited type two annexation of parcel
number 027
0063 600
02700 611 0 consisting of
5.08 plus or minus acres in the Pleasant
Township and to declare an emergency
this is through economic development
committee and Mrs hoop and Mrs crat
council member hoop um Mr President I'd
like to make a motion that Council
suspend its rules in W the second and
third readings of temporary resolution
10-25
second have a motion second to suspend
the rules and mo the second and third
reading of temporary resolution
1025 any further discussion um just that
we're asking for suspension as discussed
in finance because there is a limit of
20 days um for us to provide them with a
statement of services thank you any
further
discussion hearing none please call the
rooll on the motion to suspend Mr alss
yes Mr bisj yes Mrs CR yes Mrs hoop yes
Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes Mr Su yes
Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to suspend the
rules and wave the second and third
reading of temporary resolution 1025
passes 10 to zero council member who yes
Mr President I would like to make a
motion that Council pass Andross and
enter upon the written record temporary
resolution 10-25 second have a motion
second to pass and gross and enter upon
the written record temporary resolution
1025 any further discussion no thank you
um please call the rooll Mr alss yes Mr
bisack yes Mrs kites yes Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes Mr Su yes Miss
tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger
yes temporary resolution 1025 passes 10
to
Zer we will have no further reading of
resolutions we will now move on to the
reading of of ordinances there are no
third readings this evening of any
ordinances we will now move to the
second reading of ordinances beginning
with temporary ordinance
5624 an ordinance excuse me an ordinance
authorizing the mayor and or to acquire
a permanent access easement necessary to
perform maintenance activities on storm
water infrastructure this is through
water water pollution committee Mr Wing
and Miss tener council member Wing this
is the second of three readings second
of three readings on temporary ordinance
5624 temporary ordinance
5724 an ordinance to amend the zoning
map subject to passage of the annexation
of
22.8 plus or minus acres in Greenfield
Township and to declare an emergency
this is through Economic Development
Committee um with Mrs hoop and Mr Wing
council member hoop this is the second
of three readings second of three
readings on temporary or
57 is that a star supposed to be oh yeah
that's an amendment okay
57 okay -24 star is that
correct yes is that correct okay thank
you yeah we have to do we not have to uh
pass the
star we could we could wait till third
yeah you can do it now or you can wait
till the third reading it doesn't make
any difference Okay you Okay because in
the past we've been doing it at the time
yeah we start that's fine but you don't
have to here you have to go the full
three readings and you have a public
hearing at the next meeting so you're
going to probably address it more in
depth then anyway thank you yep thank
you law
director so second of three readings on
temporary resolution
57-4
Star first we now move to First reading
of ordinances beginning with temporary
ordinance
1-25 an ordinance to accept the fin plat
for the fairf park development this is
through code enforcement and zoning
committee Mr suy and Mrs hoop council
member suy Mr President this will be the
first of three readings first of three
readings on temporary ordinance
1-25 move to Temporary ordinance
2-25 an ordinance to amend permanent
ordinance
54-24 and to declare an emergency this
is through finance committee Mr
wolfinger and Mr ALS council member
wolfinger Mr President I like to make a
motion that Council suspends it rules
and waves the second and third reading
of temporary ordinance
2-25 second we have a motion a second to
suspend the rules and wave the second
and third reading of temporary ordinance
2-25 any discussion council member wol
finger uh briefly this as we heard uh
from U Mrs Sloan that we're making some
Personnel changes and gr changes
and responsibilities in the cord Court's
office thank you any further
discussion hearing none please call the
roll on the motion to suspend Mr ALS yes
Mr bisack yes Mrs kites yes Mr Mrs hoop
yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes Mr Su
yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to suspend the
rules and wave the second and third
reading of temporary ordinance 225
-25 uh passes 10 to Zer council member
wolfinger yes Mr President I would like
to make a motion that Council pass and
gross and Inter a written record
temporary orig
2-25 second we have a motion second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary ordinance
2-25 any further discussion uh no sir
thank you please call the rooll Mr ALS
yes Mr bisj yes Mrs Craig yes Mrs hoop
yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes Mr Sul
yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to pass Andross and
enter upon the written record temporary
ordinance 2-25 passes 10 to Zer we now
move to Temporary ordinance 325 an
ordinance to repeal Lancaster codified
ordinance part 7 business Regulation
Code chapter
711 715 721 731 785 and 791 one of the
codified ordinance of the city of
Lancaster um this is through law
committee U Mrs Kitz and Mr bisj council
member cres yes first of three readings
first of three readings on temporary
ordinance
3-25 temporary ordinance
4-25 in ordinance to amend permanent
ordinance
54-24 to authorize the service safety
director to enter into a lease contract
with the Fairfield County Commissioners
for the second floor of the city Annex
Building 123 East Chestnut Street for
juvenile court services this is through
administrative Services Mr lenberg and
Mr wolfinger council member lenberg
thank you Mr President I'd like to make
a motion that Council suspend its rules
and wave the second and third reading of
ordinance temporarily number
4-25 second we have a motion second to
suspend the rules and wave the second
and third reading of temporary ordinance
4-25 any discussion council member Lo
sir thank you hearing no discussion
please call the roll on the motion to
suspend Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs KES
yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr
skover yes Mr suy yes Miss Tiner yes Mr
Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes motion to
suspend the rules and weave the second
third reading of temporary ordinance
4-25 passes 10 to Z council member
lenberg thank you Mr President I'd like
to make a motion that Council pass
engross and enter upon the written
record ordinance temporarily number
4-25 second we have a motion of second
to pass and gross enter upon the written
record temporary ordinance
4-25 any discussion council member
lenberg as we discussed in the business
meeting this is just replacing a
three-year lease with a one-year lease
for this space to the county thank you
any further discussion hearing none
please call Ro Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes
Mrs K yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr
skover yes Mr Sully yes Miss tener yes
Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes
temporary ordinance 4-25 passes 10 to
zero we do have tabled legislation but
it's my understanding law director that
we're not taking this the recommendation
is not to take this off the table this
evening yes sir that's correct thank you
thank you with that we have concluded
the reading of uh legislation for this
evening um and we'll move on with the
business agenda um unfinished business
do we have any unfinished business any
council members with unfinished business
this
evening hearing none new business does
any council member have any new business
this evening council member Tiner yes I
just wanted to make a note to remind
everybody that if you have your um money
drafted out for our uh utilities for the
City this is not a
AE uh to get online and
uh fill out with NCR vorex is that
correct Carrie for the uh drafting for
to have your bills drafted for utilities
because the 22nd it'll be uh you won't
be able to you I guess you'll need to go
in and pay correct there is a new
website for the utilities department um
so yes you will need to go in and and
and there is no service fee uh for that
but because of uh cyber security risks
is why they have changed to that so just
it's the 20 after the 22nd you won't be
able to they won't take it out of your
accounts okay so Oh you mean for for
direct withdrawals right for savings or
checking all right thank you for that
reminder we appreciate that any other
new business for this evening
yes council member tener sorry uh so
I've been getting some calls about the
one uh water runoff uh I've spoken to
the mayor about that um if we could get
a uh presentation from the water
department storm water or something
about that because some people have sump
pumps and that was kind of the complaint
was it's going straight out to the river
and that so they don't know why you know
they would be getting a water runoff
charge on their property
so can we schedule that by chance okay
okay thank you any further new business
Mr President Mr Mayor it's uh really
just an update but it's actually uh kind
of uh good news for us last year Council
authorized uh the city to apply for the
raise grant that acronym is rebuilding
American infrastructure with
sustainability and Equity grant program
it's a DOT program to invest in um
infrastructure throughout the United
States again run by the department of
trans US Department of Transportation we
applied uh for a feasibility study for
our East Side industrial
connector that's a $800,000 Grant uh we
found out uh last late last week that we
rewarded that 800,000 that is a
non-matching 800,000 dollar grant that
will be uh administered by our city
engineer overseen by him and there'll be
some public hearings on that and
there'll be a lot of work for us to do
to make that happen but the feasibility
study is the first step and getting
truck traffic out of downtown Lancaster
so a long time project many of you know
about uh we've had uh some work done
already uh you probably saw the aeral
overview that uh the engineer put
together last year the route that it
would take this is the next step to
allow that project at least to move
forward on feasibility so $800,000 US
Department of Transportation Grant raise
Grant is what it's called Thank you Mr
Mayor great great news yes council
member will is that a reimbursement
Grant well i' have to asked the engineer
to be sure how it's done but it is 100%
uh there is no City match on that no um
audre Nettles you might explain it's not
on that one it's not the like an 820
City match some grants out there if it's
a federal or state Grant they want us to
expend the money and then they reimburse
us at 100% so is it that's not how I
understand it I understand are they
going to give the money cash up front
for us to spend or do we have to Pony up
the cash first we we'll have all that
information okay that's just what his
question I only ask because we'll need
to find a if we have to
reimburse uh or pay the they reimburse
we have to find money somewhere some
account to make it up fromont payments
certainly thank you thank you any
further new
business hearing none we'll move to the
announ anoun ment of scheduled meetings
um at regular schedule Council meetings
January 27th 2025 at 6:30 p.m. in
council chambers and then again at
February 10th
2025 at 6:30 council chambers here we
have no special scheduled meetings
regularly scheduled committee meetings
administrative service committee January
15th at 8:00 a.m. City Hall 1897
conference room finance committee
January 27th 6 p.m. City
council chambers and Safety Committee
February 7th at 8:00 a.m. City Hall 1897
conference room reading of bills there
are none at this time there's no need
for an executive session at this time I
would take a motion to adjourn Mr
President i' like to make that motion we
adjourn second we have a motion a second
to adjourn all those in favor please
signify by saying I I I I we are
adjourned please remember to sign your
legislation uh this evening thank you
[Music]
the Frankie Smith Funeral Home in
cremator in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community feel free to give us a
call at
74653 0652
stop in and see us at either of our two
locations 405 North Columbus Street in
Lancaster and 207 South Main Street in
Baltimore respect for tradition regard
for
change great automotive service is just
around the corner at the Buckeye family
of dealerships whether it's Buckeye
Nissan and hilard Georgesville Nissan at
the Georgesville Auto Mall Buckeye Honda
of Lancaster Buckeye Toyota of Lancaster
or Buckeye Collision Center in hilard
team Buckeye Services all makx and
models at each location utilizing modern
practices with hundreds of years of
experience giving you peace of mind
that's how we
[Music]
Buckeye
e e